the las vegas philharmonic is gearing up
for a very special concert tomorrow
night dedicated to ukraine as a few of
their members are from the country that
is facing so much devastation victoria
saha now with that
story the las vegas philharmonic will be
opening its saturday night concert with
a different tune
the ukrainian national anthem will be
conducted by terrace cressa his father
is ukrainian and his mother is russian
it's such a wonderful and a beautiful
culture that deserves to have a lot more
recognition so i wish that was not under
those circumstances he still has family
stuck in ukraine but wants to do
anything he can to stand up to the
atrocities being forced on ukrainians by
russian president vladimir putin it's
possible there
it
if we don't stand up to it it's possible
here too
marislova comic is also from ukraine and
will be dressed in her traditional
clothing for saturday's concert
embracing her ukrainian culture proudly
from thousands of miles away for a while
i couldn't even hold the violin because
nothing seemed to make sense anymore
but
we do
seem to find solace in making music
together victoria saha live local now